well this is such an honor i cannot
believe i'm getting a chance to talk to
brandi clark
during pride month on et canada pride
thank you so much brandi for sitting
down and chatting with me
oh thanks for having me and i'm such a
fan of your music
you are phenomenal but i want to hit on
pride of it it is
pride month what does pride mean to you
wow that's a great question i mean it's
always a fun month to me
it gives all of us a month of um
[Music]
heightened awareness yeah you know
yeah and i think that awareness is so
important and i think
that the awareness of a queer community
within the country music
genre awareness is also super
important so i appreciate you always
being out there
honest and talking about things that you
know make people feel seen themselves
whether through your music or through
what you represent and the things you
say you grew up
in a small town in washington when did
you first
know that you might be queer i was a
really late bloomer in
pretty much every way of my life i
didn't realize that i was gay until i
was in my early 20s
okay and so and you know i'm really
thankful for that because
i didn't have that added stress on
myself as a kid and it would have been
a major stressor for me and um
so i i'm really glad that i was just
kind of naively
skipping through my adolescence
you know not intended or anything like
that you know i was always really
accepted by my family which made it a
lot
easier for me um but thank god when i
think i hear about these kids or
friends of mine who um they'll be like
oh i i don't ever remember not being gay
i just remember
realizing that that nobody that not
everybody was
and that that was not okay and something
that had to be hidden and
and you know i'm glad i didn't go
through any of that
i'm glad you didn't either there are a
lot of people that have a very difficult
coming out like you just mentioned
was there any reservations um about
country music and did you have any fears
being
openly gay entering the genre of country
music
oh for sure i mean you know for me i've
loved country music my whole life
yeah and honestly i thought that once i
um once i realized that i was gay and
was not going to be in the closet about
it
i felt like a performing career was off
the table for me
um but i feel lucky in that i
um it wasn't you know it was sort of
then that things started to happen for
me
and fortunately for me there was no
there was no discussion about
being in the closet because i wasn't so
that was it's never been anything that's
even been talked about
on a record label level at least with me
around
and um and i don't even think with me
not around
um so i was lucky my mom was a huge
katie lang fan oh wow canada
canadian yes yes and i think that there
was a part of me
that always knew even though i was gay
that there would be a place for me in
country music and i think katie lang had
a lot to do with that
you and brandi carlisle are great
friends you've worked together what is
that friendship
meant to you within this industry well
you know i was a fan of brandy's
um a long ways back and the first time
that i met her
was um we did a few shows together
on the road and she's such a great
singer
like as great of a singer as she is on
record like live and so i was a big fan
of brandy's and became a bigger fan
through that and then you know started
to get to know her some
and um when i was in during the pandemic
one of the
great things that happened was i got to
record some songs with her
which probably wouldn't have happened
had we not all been locked down
and that was amazing because i've worked
with really great producers
but she's the first producer i've worked
with that her instrument is her voice
and so she really pushed me in a
different way
the two of you together are really
something special like
honestly yeah well i hope we make a
whole record together
you know i mean i have plans for that i
hope she does too
well you've worked with some cr
incredible people in your time
but i do want to hit on something here
nashville
is full of incredible queer people both
in front and behind the scenes but
nashville
and the country genre still has a long
way to go
with representation that is for sure we
are seeing people like tj osborne come
out love tj love brothers osborne
there's lily rose we're seeing people
like
orville peck and you know even trixie
mattel who was a drag performer getting
a bit of
play within the country genre
do you feel like there's a positive
shift happening i do
i do i mean i've seen things change a
lot in the time i've been in the
business
but i believe in general we
underestimate our audience
i believe the audience is way more
involved
in country music than um then they're
giving credit for
i think you're absolutely right on that
finally brandi i just want to know
what would your advice be to maybe
younger queer
artists who love country music but feel
like there may not be a place for them
within the genre you know i would just
say be great
because you know i remember early on in
knowing
shane macanally who really has been a
pivotal person in my life
for a lot of reasons i think one of the
bigger ones though was when i met him
he was an out of the closet gay man in
nashville which
at the time i didn't really know many
men and i gained a lot of um
my own strength from him and
but i said something one time to him
about um
do you think anybody will like be
against us because we're gay
and he said to me it won't matter we're
too good
yes and i think that that's really the
advice i would give is whatever
whatever it is just be great at
at your craft i believe that i believe
there's always a space
for greatness